What you're about to see is going to melt your brain
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
There have been a couple of new R-rated and hardcore
Marvel projects that have been announced
for the next couple of years, confirming a big theory
the love you had about the darker,
more supernatural team ups.
So we'll break it all down
in how Marvel is treating their new R-rated movies.
And it shows because previously they a Deadpool
three was going to be rated R,
but now it looks like there's a bunch of different
types of mature projects that are going to make.
you know, a lot of it has to do with the new Marvel
Spotlight brand that they're introducing.
Echo is going to be like the first big project
that's part of that, like their R-rated projects.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
It's still really early days, but it does sound like
they're doing this great big pivot at Marvel.
Like, let's try really different stuff
that isn't anything like we've done before,
which is where this darker,
more supernatural team up stuff comes in,
also them doing just flat out rated R stuff in general.
that's one of the whole reasons
why they created this new Marvel Spotlight brand
so they could differentiate their more hardcore
R-rated stuff,
But the past few weeks, you might have seen people
talking about the new Midnight Suns announcement.
It looks like Marvel is finally developing
a midnight Suns team
and based on the roster of characters, it looks like
it's going to be a movie, not a TV series.
so be rated R instead of mature.
They're just different designations for that type
of stuff, depending on which country you live in.
So whatever they call rated R stuff in your country
generally meant to be the more hardcore
adult themed stuff.
There are couple surprises on this announced
first roster too.
Like this first version of the team.
I knew they would do more
supernatural teams in general.
I think we all expected at some point
because we've been seeing those characters
show up in new movies and series
Originally they had a plan to start doing that.
The big supernatural team ups
in the new Mahershala Ali Blade movie,
they kind of did one at the end of the Eternals movie.
Like that was meant to be a teaser
for their first version of the new Blade movie.
that was actually the first legit
appearance of Mahershala
Ali as Blade character inside the MCU just in general.
even though you only hear his voice, he asks Kit
Harington's Black Knight character, Dane Whitman.
Are you sure you're ready for that?
When he's about to touch the Ebony blade?
All because originally I think they plan to introduce
more Black Night stuff during that first Blade movie.
but this is a couple of years ago.
The Blade movie changed like a couple times
and they just announced now
that a new version of it is going to be much smaller
with fewer team-up characters,
but it will be rated R more hardcore,
which I think is good news.
So a lot of their previous crossover plans
have just shifted a lot.
But in general,
there's been a lot of chaos going on at Marvel.
So no surprise that their plans have changed
it just sounds like they're holding off
on their team up,
making it like its own separate, much bigger thing,
which I think is totally fine,
kind of like a darker spin on The Avengers.
But with Supernatural characters,
you introduce a bunch of them
in separate movies and shows,
then you start to tease their crossovers.
In Post-Credits scenes like this.
Mahershala Ali Blade Post-Credits
scene with Black Knight in the Eternals
movie, used to tease how they're all connected
through some overarching threat or villain.
Then you put them on their big team in this new movie,
some of the characters
that are supposed to be on this
first version of the team they've already introduced.
But some of the projects that are part of
it have not happened yet.
we just go down the list of the characters
that are supposed to be on this first version
of the team and which movies and shows
are supposed to be connected to it, at least right now.
Some of them have not been announced yet,
and this is meant to be completely separate
from Avengers five, Avengers six.
Whatever happens with the mainline Avengers storyline
or like the new X-Men movies that are coming up,
it looks like the Midnight Suns
team will be led by Mahershala Ali as Blade and Wong.
Of all people, which kind of surprised me to hear
about the idea of them teaming up.
It sounds like it's going to start
at the end of the new Blade movie.
Maybe in a post-credits scene
like the actual Blade movie itself
will be relatively small compared
to what people thought it was going to be before,
but it sounds like they're going to use it
to start setting up the supernatural team.
maybe like a classic Iron Man one Post-Credits scene
callback with Wong doing his best.
Nick Fury with the darker characters
we're putting together a team.
they literally just did a more jokey parody
on this concept with Kamala Khan.
Ms.. Marvel putting together
The Young Avengers, starting with Kate Bishop.
Probably one of the next big surprises I saw on this
initial roster was Elizabeth Olsen's Scarlet Witch.
I would not have expected them to put her on the team
because she's rumored
to be in so many big crossovers down the road.
then there's moonlight in Werewolf by Night.
No surprise there.
I don't know about man thing because he did debut
during the werewolf by Night series.
He is a supernatural character.
There's a lot of supernatural related stuff going on.
You have Elsa Bloodstone,
also a big supernatural character.
But Moon Knight.
And Werewolf by night have been rumored
for big supernatural team ups for a long time.
it sounds like Marvel just changed
which teams they would be on and when they would
come back Originally, I believe they planned to put Kit
Harington's, Black Knight
and Moon Knight in that first new Blade movie
before the script changed a billion times.
now they're not supposed to be in that movie,
There hasn't been a ton of talk about ghostwriter
other than they're going to introduce the character
in the MCU at some point in the next couple of years.
I haven't heard of which movie that's going to be.
They've been teasing the concept
of the character in the last couple
of really big supernatural related movies
they're couple Easter eggs for ghostwriter
during Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness.
But like the actual character
did not appear in that movie.
it sounds like we might get a version
of one of the older ghostwriter characters
to return in Avengers Secret Wars.
Like some of the characters are coming back
from the X-Men movies, and that's where they're waiting
to introduce
the new MCU version of Ghost Writer worried.
Are you going to have a couple versions
of Spider-Man active at the same time
for a little while, while Avengers five and Avengers
six are going on?
they're even going to clown on this idea with Deadpool
three to like picture the Avengers Assemble scene
in Avengers Endgame, but like a parody version
with a bunch of variants of Deadpool doing it
Deadpool core assemble maximum effort
the rumored villains for this first midnight Sons
movie would either be Lilith or Mephisto
Mephisto is supposed to debut
during the Ironheart series
and he's supposed to be played by Sacha Baron Cohen.
Reportedly, he already filmed some scenes for that,
but then they delayed the Ironheart series
because they wanted it to take place
alongside the Armor Wars movie,
which they turned into a movie
and then delayed it for a couple of years.
So Ironheart just kind of hit the shelf
and it's sitting there for a couple more years.
Lilith was supposed to be in the new Blade movie.
She might still be the main villain
in that generally in the comics,
Lilith story is based on a lot of the biblical
mythological tales about the character,
like she was the bride of Satan or Lucifer
in some stories, or Mephisto in other stories.
She rebelled against the MCU version of the one
true God like capital of God.
He does exist in the Marvel Universe, but he's so OP
he kind of breaks any story that he's in.
Like, how come God let this happen?
so generally that's why you don't see him
actually showing up in a ton of stories.
but like, there's an MCU iteration
of the Christian version of heaven
in the back story that you read about in the Bible.
Like the whole war between Lucifer and God,
the rebellion in heaven.
Lilith was cast down to hell with him.
Everyone else that rebelled.
she's also meant to have been the very first human
woman, the original wife of the biblical Adam,
who left him
in, went to Mephisto before Eve was created.
so the couple versions of her origin, just based on
which character is telling it, in which comic book
she's in, she shows up in a lot of Ghost
Rider stories specifically.
And as you would expect, Midnight Suns Team-Up stories.
So it makes sense they would want to use her
in the new Midnight Suns movie.
In fact, she was actually the very first villain
that the Midnight
Sun Space
when the team formed for the first time in the comics.
it was basically the Midnight Suns coming together
to fight Lilith in a bunch of her demonic children.
Marvel hasn't said when the Midnight Suns
movie would actually happen,
but it wouldn't be till after all of these connected
movies and shows happen.
Maybe some of the other characters are introduced
like Ghost Rider, for instance,
and some of the team members return to the MCU.
A really good
example is Elizabeth Olsen, Scarlet Witch.
they just announced they're working on Moon Knight
Season two.
That would also help set up Midnight Suns,
and that's going to be a couple of years away,
at least The brand new Blade movie
still also a couple of years away.
Ironheart, like I said, delayed a couple of years.
It would take place right next to the Armor Wars movie.
That's not happening for a while.
Marvel Zombies is also supposed to be connected
to this new Midnight Suns project,
but is animated in a separate thing from the
What if Marvel
Zombies episode in season
one that's coming in 2025 at some point?
Not really sure when during the year, but
they'll probably release a trailer at some point soon.
but Midnight Suns would be at least 3 to 4 years away
and that could change.
But right now they're still trying to release
the new version of Avengers five in 2026.
Hopefully that doesn't get delayed again
I just did a couple of videos
about how they're changing Avengers five
and what happened with Jonathan Majors,
like how Marvel dealt with all that I know.
There's tons of questions about other darker characters
like Punisher.
Doctor Strange Punisher is going to be
one of the main characters during Daredevil Born Again
there was also some language in the Echo trailer
that sounds kind of like Punisher
Easter Eggs, so they might tease him during Echo too.
but let me know in the comments.
Who do you want to be on this first midnight Suns team?
Remember the first Avengers team
only really had six people on the roster,
so it'd probably be a similar situation for Midnight
Suns like six people or less on the first roster.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
We're going to see Scarlet Witch come back in.
What if Season 2 Episode 8
My video for that will post tomorrow,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so don't miss that.
Click here for that video, I'll update the link
as soon as I post that, and click here to learn
what happened to Jonathan Majors
with Marvel behind the scenes.
Thank you so much for watching
Happy holidays everyone,
and I'll see you guys in the next one!